oh I'm really gonna never get that walk
from one song out of my head am i black
mirror time again and it's one that I
know a lot of people have been saying
they really aren't justed to see my
reaction to and that is shut up and
dance so this one I have a feeling that
this one did not impact me as harshly as
it did a lot of people judging by not
only my own comment section but sort of
popping on to IMDB of reading some user
reviews cuz I I the once it ended I
found myself thinking okay that was good
but like did I miss something cuz I
didn't like I did it I didn't have my
mind blown by the twist that I had in
store one of them actually honestly I
kind of don't like for a reason that
might be unique to me but I'll come back
to that and you know I found myself
going no it's good I wouldn't say it's
not good but it's not it's it's not mind
blowing and it's not really messing with
me
emotionally the way that a lot of these
things do and so I've had to dig into
the reviews a little bit i-i-i think
it's mainly that final reveal about
kenny and and the nature of exactly what
it was that he did that it's being used
to blackmail him which gives a lot of
people that oh yeah i guess sort of that
icky feeling because I get I get
spoilers it's in the title the the fact
that you come to realize that you have
been feeling bad for and in a way
rooting for you know a pedophile and you
know that's I think that's a probably a
very uncomfortable and rather sickening
feeling for a lot of people and and I
understand that first some well
I think I know why it didn't hit me
quite the way I wanted which was that
there was something about the episode
prior to that revealed that I really
liked and that revealed kind of took it
away and this happened to me to a
certain extent with hang the DJ as well
because I kind of liked in how the logic
of that one worked internally better
than the final reveal of what was
actually going on and you get the bigger
picture and go oh so it wasn't quite
what I thought it was but I really liked
what I thought it was so in this case
what I liked about the way it appeared
to be prior to that final reveal was
that they just needed this dumb kid to
you know just be scared enough to give
his phone number initially and and you
know they've got a video of him jerking
off and you get someone young enough
someone scared enough someone in an
uncertain enough place in their social
life and they're standing and in you
know what their future is and you can I
can buy that he makes that first mistake
of giving his phone number based off
just not wanting a jerk off video out
there and then what happened after that
as things got pushed further it what I
liked about what I thought was going on
was he was being pushed to do things
that were no longer reasonable to simply
cover up the jerk off video cuz I mean
initially go to this location okay take
this cake okay deliver it to this guy
okay so you know once he started pushing
to the level that is like okay this is
the point where he would go no it's not
worth it for what it what it is that
they're going to expose me for when it
hit that point he was being paired with
characters who had a lot more to lose
than he did and who were going to push
him and made sure that he did it so that
they held up their end as well initially
we had that you know with the with the
guy from the hotel and then later on the
guy with the guy
the woods so like that fight to the
death you don't need Kenny to be willing
to step it up to be in a fight to the
death you only need the other gotta do
it so they can ease them fighting for
his own life so I liked this idea that
what he did wasn't even that bad but it
was it scared him enough to get him in
and then once he was in the system or
whoever was doing this kept setting him
up with people that would ensure he kept
getting pushed by them if not by the
threat of blackmail in and of itself so
the final reveal that what they had on
him I eat what he was jerking off to
actually did justify as a hard word but
did make sense that he was gonna go that
distance even if he wasn't being paired
off with people who would he kept
pushing him that it's not a bad twist
but it it for me it took away an aspect
that I really liked and and made the the
episode something else instead and it's
not a poorly thought out to us it's not
a poorly played twist it's just this is
just a case where what gets lost because
you find out oh it wasn't that isn't I I
put more I I had more interest in what
we lost rather than what we gained and
what we gained was just sort of a little
feeling towards Kenny which I suppose
for other people just hit them harder
then it hit me I mean it's not like I'm
going oh it's fine well no that's maybe
uncomfortable and it's messed up but it
didn't ad it didn't hit me to my core
and also that unfortunately intellectual
the non emotional part of my brain
kicked in almost a medium when oh that
thing that I like that's not really what
was going on so that kind of also
lessened the impact of this this final
twist this final reveal I've been mainly
about the the back end of business
better now that I've talked all about
the ending let's back up for a minute
this is well constructed and the
escalation is very
well pasted across the whole thing and I
I suppose another thing is I figure
eventually he's somebody's gonna be
asked to kill somebody there's no way
this doesn't go to that level so you
know the fight to the death I don't know
if that was supposed to be like a oh my
god like who didn't like the mythos
stuff started like that's the final
point of escalation it has to be why
else do this so that I also start coming
but it does still pace itself really
well and it brings in other people at
the right way I did love it Nakia at
that door it gets open up but I mean
like you know that you know Game of
Thrones us what I know him from so that
that was that was fun that immediately
kind of was like oh this is just got
even better cuz I like him a lot well I
mean I loved him on Game of Thrones he's
that's a terrific character Mike I just
like him as a presence any and he worked
really well for this and again I bought
it with him pushing things you know
because of the threat of losing his kids
that he that he was pushing a bit harder
then then Kenny was and he was taking
the reins a bit more on the whole
situation and of course the very end all
the stuff gets leaked anyway because of
course it does
why that's always the the thing and it's
why I think in a case of some way this
it's important that these messages keep
coming at a rapid pace and it keeps
these people moving and keeps their
adrenaline pumping because that yo
you're in fight or flight basically and
that keeps you from slowing out stopping
thinking why would they not release this
after I'm done but what do they what do
they have to lose if they're already
willing to mess with me this much why
would they not mess with me that one
extra mile and release it regardless but
you know you keep people moving you keep
failing you keep dangling the carrot in
front of them and you know is as long as
you don't overplay your hand they'll
keep pushing it but of course they're
gonna release a regardless why wouldn't
they they have nothing to lose and if
they're if they're doing this for any
level of amuse
but that's probably funny to them so I
mean so in a way that was another thing
that I saw coming I don't know if it was
something that caught all the people
off-guard but I mean I genuinely just
don't know but you know again just
watching just just getting a snapshot of
ruin to life after ruined life after
ruined life and just oh boy wasn't worth
it was it and yeah I I feel like I'd
probably come off as being down on the
episode I'm not I really like you but I
feel like I I had to I've spent a lot of
the last half-hour or so just sort of
working over in my head why this didn't
hit me the way that it seemed to hit a
lot of people or as hard as it did and
that so that's what I've put the most
thought into that's what I ended up
talking the most about but it's good I
mean it's really good the the acting is
all good like I said it's incredibly
well paced
it moves at a good clip and it escalates
at a at the correct levels and at the
correct pacing and you know it if I
didn't have my intellectual brain taking
me out of that moment you know and and
recognizing you know the the lost aspect
that I talked about already that final
that final reveal about Kenny probably
would have hit me harder if not for that
and it would have given me that oh god
you know that that realization that
you've you've had sympathy or even
empathy with somebody that all of a
sudden you learned this horrible thing
about it it just makes you like sick to
your core and I didn't have that and I
might have if I if I didn't have that
you know that whole thing going on that
I talked about you know the losing the
element of the story that I thought was
there that I had really liked and I
couldn't stop my brain from kind of
registering that immediately
so whatever impact that moment had it
wasn't enough for like it wasn't like I
had the thought after the episode ended
like oh but it kind of it kind of took
away that thing instead I had it like
as I was watching and sort of took me
out of the emotional moment I suspect
that is just me though so I'm weird
that's the upshot of all this but shut
up and dance have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about this all the
stuff to do like support me on patreon
and send stuff to my Bo box and follow
me on Twitter bla bla bla bla bla bla
links for all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]